Es ist 12:30 Uhr,
ich habe noch nichts gefrühstückt.
Ich habe das letzte Mal gegessen,
gestern Abend um 7 oder 8 Uhr.
*Musik*
Herzlich willkommen zu
Schönschlaus Fastenexperiment.
Kann man ohne weiteres drei Tage
lang, ohne feste Nahrung auskommen?
Und stellt sich nach diesen
drei Tagen eine Fasteneuphorie ein?
Der Mensch kann ja angeblich über 30
Tage ohne feste Nahrung auskommen.
Zumindest habe ich das selber
noch behauptet im letzten Video.
Schaut es euch an.
Heute ist Donnerstag vor Ostern.
Ich habe beschlossen,
es wie die Christen zu machen.
Das Fasten wird bei den Christen
mit der Ostermesse gebrochen,
Samstagabend.
So werde ich es auch machen.
Das war gar nicht so leicht,
drei Tage zu finden,
wo ich nicht unbedingt
meine Gehirnshöchstleistung brauche.
Für die nächsten Tage habe ich
mir vorgenommen, Videos aufzunehmen,
äh... Buchhaltung
und Papierkram zu machen.
Und die Wohnung einzurichten,
aufzuräumen.
Weil wir hier gerade neu eingezogen
sind, ich hier mein Studio einrichte
Ich glaube, Melanie ist so stolz
auf mich, dass ich endlich mal was
bei unserem Instagram Account mache.
Das ist ein Instagram-Post
zu diesem Vlog,
der wiederum zu letztem Video ist.
Social Media Inception.
Das bedeutet, Freunde der Sonne,
wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert,
wie mein unfassbar spannendes Leben
sonst so aussieht,
dann folgt uns
auf Instagram@schoenschlau.
Mit OE wohlgemerkt. Da tobe ich mich
ab und an ein wenig aus.
Zumindest an spannenden Tagen,
so wie heute.
Wenn ich dabei bin,
mich live zu Tode zu hungern.
*stöhnt*
Ohne Witz, ich denke heute
schon zum 10. Mal:
"Hm, ich könnte ja was essen."
Oder: "Was könnte ich denn essen?"
Dann fällt es mir wieder ein.
Da merkt man erst mal,
wie oft man am Tag an Essen denkt.
Es ist 14:30 Uhr und ich kann
an nichts anderes e.., ich...
Ich wollte gerade sagen:
Ich an nichts anderes essen.
Hm, nichts wirklich, hungern.
*lacht*
Ja.
Wenn es irgendwie nicht geht,
dann breche ich es ab.
Ich muss es dann nur dokumentieren.
Ach so, falls ihr euch fragt, ob
ich mich eigentlich den ganzen Tag
nicht vom Fleck bewege,
so ähnlich ist es tatsächlich.
Ich spare mir meine Energie auf.
*stöhnt*
Leute, ich habe mir
einen Kaffee gemacht.
Ich glaube, das ist eine dumme Idee.
Aber ich habe so Lust,
erstmal auf was warmes.
Das erinnert mich
doch ein bisschen an Essen.
*schlürft*
*stöhnt zufrieden*
Es ist ganz schlimm, es ist 16:15
Uhr und mein Mann macht sich gerade
Pancakes mit Bananen,
die noch vom Frühstück übrig sind.
Und es riecht so gut.
Ich glaube,
ich muss an die frische Luft.
Es begann damit, dass die Pfanne
so schön knisterte.
Das ist der erste Zucker, den
ich zu mir nehme, seit 36 Stunden.
Momentan fühle ich mich so,
als könnte ich das heute
nicht durchhalten.
Nachdem ich jetzt 15 Minuten
lethargisch rumsaß
und...
...nichts machen konnte...
...esse ich jetzt ein Knäckebrot.
*knuspert genussvoll*
Hm, Essen!
Ich glaube,
danach lege ich mich noch mal hin.
Kurzes Update. Ich bin schlafen
gegangen nach dem Knäckebrot.
Im Moment geht es mir
gerade eigentlich wieder gut.
Mein Mann, Matthias, der der
beste ist, fastet heute mit mir mit.
Damit ich das besser durchhalte
und aus Solidarität.
Ja, es ist immer ein Wechsel
zwischen: es völlig bereuen,
dass ich das überhaupt mache.
Und einem Gefühl von: es geht
mir doch eigentlich ganz gut.
Erstaunlich. Jedenfalls habe ich
gerade wieder ein unglaubliches Low.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich kann nichts mehr machen.
Deswegen esse ich jetzt
1,5 Scheiben Käse.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher,
dass man das so nicht richtig macht.
Ich bin ein
ganz schlechtes Beispiel.
Das Gute ist, ich glaube,
die wenigsten von euch
machen es zuhause nach.
Weil es einfach keinen Spaß macht.
Ich befürchte, ich muss
einen kleinen Powernap halten.
Ich saß die letzte Stunde einfach
nur auf einem Stuhl im Wohnzimmer
und fand das
unglaublich anstrengend.
Ich schaue schon
die ganze Zeit Werbung,
wo leckeres Essen angepriesen wird
und ich verspüre keinen Appetit.
Es ist fast 22:30 Uhr abends
und ich fühle mich ziemlich fit.
Super wach. Leute, ich weiß
nicht, ob das jetzt der Punkt ist.
Aber meine Stimmung
ist definitiv gestiegen.
Tag 3.
Der Tag startet heute definitiv
viel besser als gestern.
Das liegt natürlich auch daran,
dass ich weiß, dass wir heute Abend
endlich wieder was
zu essen bekommen.
Seit gestern Abend 23:00 Uhr
geht es mir relativ gut.
Kleiner Tipp, man denkt viel
langsamer ohne Zucker im Blut.
Nach 48 Stunden jetzt
oder fast 48 Stunden ohne Zucker.
Ja!
Wenn ihr ein langes Wochenende
haben wollt, einfach nicht essen.
Die Zeit vergeht
wirklich deutlich langsamer.
Gestern saßen wir uns zum Beispiel
ab uns zu mal zu zweit gegenüber,
so 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Ohne etwas zu machen,
ohne etwas zu sagen.
Man ist halt einfach
nicht so fix im Kopf.
Also wenn wir einen Autounfall
bauen, musst du das gleich löschen.
Es geht mir gerade wieder
schon so ein bisschen elend.
Ich habe so Hunger.
Ich muss mich kurz hinsetzen,
es ist so anstrengend.
Mental geht es mir super,
aber körperlich...
*stöhnt entkräftet*
Ich bin so kaputt,
ich habe einfach keine Energie.
Ich glaube, ich muss mich
tatsächlich noch mal hinlegen.
Und kurz schlafen.
Fastet lieber nicht, wenn ihr
nicht die Gelegenheit dazu habt,
sehr viel zu schlafen.
Es ist jetzt 14:00 Uhr,
ich habe sehr unruhig geschlafen.
Aber, nur noch 5 Stunden
bis zum Essen.
Wir haben 18:00 Uhr am dritten Tag.
Ich habe es also fast geschafft.
Drei Tage Fasten.
Mein Fazit ist: ich bin erst mal
erstaunt, dass es doch so gut ging.
Dafür, dass wir sonst immer dreimal
am Tag essen, zwischendrin auch,
bin ich ziemlich erstaunt, wie
gut man tatsächlich noch leben kann.
Wenn man so gut wie nichts isst.
Man hat zwischendrin
tatsächlich Phasen,
in denen man überhaupt
keinen Hunger mehr verspürt.
Man kann Werbung von Schokokuchen
schauen, es lässt einen völlig kalt.
1 Stunde später sieht man in
der Küche nur den Kochtopf stehen
und wird verrückt.
Ich könnte mir schon vorstellen,
dass es ganz gut wäre,
einmal im Jahr
eine Fastenkur zu machen.
Also nicht so, irgendwie im Alltag,
sondern mit Programm und Experten.
Wichtig ist glaube ich,
dass man sich wirklich Zeit nimmt,
das als eine Art Urlaub
oder Kur ansieht.
Und nicht einfach denkt,
ich esse jetzt einfach mal nichts.
Man merkt schon, Matthias hat
einen trainierteren Stoffwechsel.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich daran,
dass er Marathon läuft.
Er war echt heute Morgen laufen,
weil er nicht schlafen konnte.
Das hätte ich nicht hinbekommen.
Was ich klar feststelle, dass ich
körperlich sehr wenig Energie habe.
Wir waren heute
etwas draußen, einkaufen,
das fand ich
unglaublich anstrengend.
Ich freue mich einfach so sehr
auf das Essen in einer Stunde.
Wir haben Brot bekommen.
Wir müssen uns jetzt
ein bisschen zusammenreißen,
dass wir das nicht komplett
in uns hineinschlingen.
*stöhnt genussvoll*
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk